Today's show is brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. As we make our way through life, all of us have access to a rich repository of wisdom. This storehouse of knowledge can help us make better decisions, cultivate closer relationships, and enhance the quality of our work.
今天的节目由 T-Mobile for Business 赞助播出。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是 Shankar Vedantam。在我们的人生旅途中，我们每个人都能接触到丰富的智慧宝库。这个知识宝库可以帮助我们做出更好的决策，建立更亲密的关系，并提高我们的工作质量。
It can help us be better partners and parents, better artists and writers, better entrepreneurs and leaders. How do we tap into this deep well of insight? We need to listen to others who know more than us and to learn from those who see more clearly than we do. Whether it's a veteran member of our profession, a seasoned parent or grandparent, or a couple with decades of marriage behind them, other people can provide us with tools, expertise,
它可以帮助我们成为更好的伴侣和父母，更好的艺术家和作家，更好的企业家和领导者。我们该如何挖掘这口深邃的洞察力之井呢？我们需要倾听那些比我们懂得更多的人，向那些看得比我们更透彻的人学习。无论是我们行业中的资深前辈，经验丰富的父母或祖父母，还是结婚几十年的夫妻，其他人都能为我们提供工具、专业知识，
and insight in calculably valuable assets in any life. So why is it, given all the wisdom we have with an easy reach, we so often resist or reject what other people have to tell us? This week on Hidden Brain, the curious psychological tendency that keeps us from acquiring all the knowledge available to us and how we can open ourselves to learn from others. All over the world, people want to be free. Individual autonomy is especially prized in a country like the United States. Who decides what you study in college? You do.
以及洞察力——这在任何人生中都是不可估量的宝贵财富。那么，既然我们触手可及拥有如此多的智慧，为什么我们却常常抗拒或拒绝别人告诉我们的东西呢？本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们将探讨那种阻碍我们获取现有知识的奇特心理倾向，以及我们如何敞开心扉向他人学习。在世界各地，人们都渴望自由。个人自主权在美国这样的国家尤其受到重视。谁决定你在大学学什么？你自己决定。
Who decides who you marry or where you live? You do. Who decides what food you eat, what movies you watch, what songs you listen to? You do, you do, you do. At Dominican University in California, psychologist Benjamin Rosenberg studies how people respond to real and imagined infringements on their sense of autonomy. Ben Rosenberg, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. Ben, I want to take you back many years to when you were in college and driving one day in Boulder, Colorado. Three of your roommates were in your Jeep Cherokee.
谁决定你和谁结婚或住在哪里？你自己决定。谁决定你吃什么食物，看什么电影，听什么歌？你自己决定，你自己决定，你自己决定。在加州的道明尼大学，心理学家 Benjamin Rosenberg 研究人们如何应对现实中和想象中对自己自主权的侵犯。Ben Rosenberg，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你的邀请。Ben，我想带你回到多年前你上大学时，有一天在科罗拉多州博尔德开车的情景。你的三个室友当时都在你的吉普切诺基车里。
You were headed to a nearby golf course. Can you paint me a picture of what happened that day? Oh, goodness. So we're driving up the freeway, the 36 freeway to be specific. And we're cruising along in my Jeep, just like four college guys do. And a small kind of Geo Metro-ish car pulls up behind us and is like tailgating us like nobody's business. The other driver was trying to force Ben
你们正前往附近的一个高尔夫球场。你能给我描述一下那天发生了什么吗？哦，天哪。我们当时正沿着高速公路行驶，具体来说是 36 号高速公路。我们开着我的吉普车，就像四个大学生常做的那样。一辆类似 Geo Metro 的小车跟在我们后面，像疯了一样紧贴着我们行驶。另一名司机试图强迫 Ben
to move out of the lane. And I really feel threatened by this. I'm like, what is this guy doing? What's happening here? I really didn't like what was going on. So as a whatever 21 year old, what do you do? But you slam on your brakes to tell the person, Hey, get off my butt. So the guy takes exception to this. He pulls into the lane next to us. We're in the fast lane, the left lane, The guy pulls into the lane next to us and rolls down his window and starts shouting obscenities
离开车道。我真的感到受到了威胁。我在想，这家伙在干什么？这到底是怎么回事？我真的很不喜欢发生的事情。作为一个 21 岁的年轻人，你会怎么做？你猛踩刹车告诉那个人，嘿，离我远点。所以那家伙对此很不满。他开进了我们旁边的车道。我们在快车道，也就是左侧车道，那家伙开进旁边的车道，摇下车窗开始大声辱骂
at my roommate tonight in the car. Well, you'd think there's one of two directions my response could go, right? I could let it go, let the guy drive away. Naturally, that is not what I did. I also rolled down the window and started yelling back at the guy. And so we're having this shouting match. It's 70 miles per hour cruising down the freeway,
我车里的室友。好吧，你可能会认为我的反应会有两种方向，对吧？我可以放过他，让他开车离开。自然，我没有那样做。我也摇下车窗开始对着那家伙大喊大叫。于是我们就在高速公路上以每小时 70 英里的速度进行了一场叫骂，
which is truly looking back on it, a ridiculously unsafe thing to be doing. And the guy decides he's's gonna speed up, pull in front of us, and then do the brake check thing back to us, right? So he slams on his brakes. Wow. Luckily we, luckily we don't, we don't hit the guy. I sort of see what's coming and you know I'm like, I'm beyond limit at this point. I'm freaking out and my roommates basically say, dude, chill out. You gotta let it go. And it was just enough for whatever reason
回想起来，这确实是一件极其不安全的事情。那家伙决定加速，开到我们前面，然后对我们进行“刹车测试”，对吧？所以他猛踩刹车。哇。幸运的是，我们没有撞到他。我预感到了会发生什么，你知道，我当时已经到了极限。我快疯了，我的室友基本上说，伙计，冷静点。你得放手。不管出于什么原因，这已经足够
to get through to me. And I thankfully let the guy just kind of speed off down the highway. Now it turns out this wasn't a completely isolated incident, Ben, because I understand more recently you were driving in your car with your wife and children when you had another altercation on the road. Tell me what happened this time. Yeah, I think my wife will probably kill me for sharing this, but here we go. So,
让我清醒过来了。谢天谢地，我让那家伙加速开走了。现在看来，这并不是一个完全孤立的事件，Ben，因为我了解到最近你和妻子孩子开车时又发生了一次路怒冲突。告诉我这次发生了什么。是的，我想我妻子可能会因为我分享这件事而杀了我，但我们开始吧。所以，
we had flown home to the Bay Area from a wedding in Minnesota with two kids. My daughter is about three months at the time, my son's about four and a half, and we go to my parents house. It's Rosh Hashanah. We have a lovely dinner with everybody. We're quite tired though, and so we load everybody up in the car, sun setting, to drive home. My parents live on a relatively small residential street, and so you need to do a three point turn in order to get going the correct direction to get back out of their neighborhood.
我们带着两个孩子从明尼苏达州参加完婚礼飞回湾区。我女儿当时大约三个月大，我儿子大约四岁半，我们去了我父母家。那是犹太新年。我们和大家一起吃了顿愉快的晚餐。不过我们很累，所以我们把所有人都装进车里，太阳下山了，准备开车回家。我父母住在一个相对较小的住宅区街道上，所以你需要做一个三点掉头才能走正确的方向离开他们的社区。
And so I'm finishing my three point turn and a new Ford Bronco flies up the street. And it says again, a windy road. You need to go pretty slowly around here. Flies up the street at us. And I think he sees us and he stops, but it seems like he very reluctantly stops. And he's like creeping towards us,
我正在完成我的三点掉头，一辆新的福特 Bronco 飞快地冲上街道。再说一次，这是一条蜿蜒的道路。你需要在这里慢慢开。它飞快地冲向我们。我想他看到了我们，他停了下来，但看起来他非常不情愿地停了下来。他正向我们缓慢移动，
revving his engine up. Wow. So I take this as an affront, and I decide, well, you know, I'm gonna finish my turn as slowly as I can, just to kind of put a little salt on the wound here, because this guy clearly seems like he's really in a rush, and he's annoying
轰鸣着引擎。哇。所以我把这视为一种侮辱，我决定，好吧，你知道，我要尽可能慢地完成我的掉头，只是为了在伤口上撒点盐，因为这家伙看起来真的很赶时间，而且他很烦人，
me, so why not make it a little more slowly? Convinced that the driver of the Ford Bronco was infringing on his autonomy to make a three-point turn in peace, Ben rolled down his window and yelled an insult. The guy rolls his window back down at me and starts yelling back at us. At this point my wife is already like beyond furious and and she knows as I have a history of getting upset on the road, I have a road rage history, and so she's beyond upset already. I figure incidents over you know we're gonna drive away so I start driving down the road my parents live in a pretty windy kind of hilly neighborhood and there's some speed bumps so you know, we're gonna drive away. So I start driving down the road. My parents live in a pretty windy, kind of hilly neighborhood, and there's some speed bumps.
所以我为什么不让它慢一点呢？Ben 确信福特 Bronco 的司机侵犯了他平静地进行三点掉头的自主权，于是摇下车窗大喊侮辱。那家伙也摇下车窗对着我们大喊大叫。此时我妻子已经愤怒到了极点，她知道我有在路上发火的记录，我有路怒史，所以她已经非常生气了。我以为事件结束了，你知道我们要开车离开，所以我开始开车沿着路走，我父母住在一个相当蜿蜒、多山的社区，有一些减速带，所以你知道，我们要开车离开。所以我开始开车沿着路走。我父母住在一个相当蜿蜒、多山的社区，有一些减速带。
So, you know, you gotta go pretty slow down the road. So I start driving away, and I see in the rear view, the guy pulls a three-point turn of his own now. Oh my gosh. Right, and decides to pursue us, to follow us back down the street. And so... He's coming after you.
所以，你知道，你必须在路上开得很慢。所以我开始开车离开，我在后视镜里看到，那家伙现在自己也做了一个三点掉头。哦，天哪。对，他决定追赶我们，跟着我们回到街上。所以……他在追你。
He's coming after us! down the street and so he's coming after you he's coming after us and I think to myself oh crap you know what what have I done I've got my wife and my kids in the car but at this point we're in so deep that I have to keep going right so I start driving down the road again you can't go very fast we're going around these turns I grew up in this neighborhood my parents have lived there for 35 years, and I figure I'll turn off this main road before we get to the really main road and I will lose the guy.
他在追我们！沿着街道，所以他在追你，他在追我们，我心想，哦，该死，你知道我做了什么？我的妻子和孩子都在车里，但此时我们已经陷得太深了，我必须继续前进，对吧？所以我又开始开车沿着路走，你不能开得太快，我们绕过这些弯道，我在这个社区长大，我父母在那里住了 35 年，我想在到达真正的主路之前我会转出这条主路，我会甩掉那个家伙。
So I take a turn up this street, thinking I know exactly where it's gonna lead me, and it turns out to be a dead end. And so we ended a cul-de-sac in some person's driveway. And at this point, panic really sets in. And so I need to do this three point turn to get out of this cul-de-sac. And in my really heightened state,
所以我转进这条街，以为我知道它会带我去哪里，结果却是一条死胡同。所以我们最终停在了一个死胡同里，在某人的车道上。此时，恐慌真的开始了。所以我需要做这个三点掉头才能离开这个死胡同。在我非常紧张的状态下，
I end up ignoring all the warning bells in her car that are beeping at me in the camera. And I wham her back bumper and her tail light into this cement wall. Oh no. And my son who's in the back goes, daddy, what was that? And my wife of course knows I've just rammed her nice car into this wall. And so I finished the turn and start driving out.
我最终忽略了车里所有对我发出警告的蜂鸣声和摄像头。我猛地把她的后保险杠和尾灯撞到了水泥墙上。哦，不。坐在后面的儿子说，爸爸，那是什么？我妻子当然知道我刚刚把她漂亮的车撞到了墙上。所以我完成了掉头，开始开车出去。
Luckily the guy hadn't followed us into this dead end, into this cul-de-sac. But I mean, it was a really scary thing to have happen that, you know, quite truthfully, like I had caused, right? I was the cause of this incident. I want to fast forward you to another story that took place in your life, Ben. Some years ago, when the COVID-19 pandemic hit, you and your wife and son were living with your parents.
幸运的是，那家伙没有跟着我们进入这个死胡同。但是，我的意思是，发生这种事真的很可怕，你知道，说实话，就像是我造成的，对吧？我是这次事件的起因。我想带你回到你生命中发生的另一个故事，Ben。几年前，当新冠疫情爆发时，你和你的妻子儿子和你父母住在一起。
So you got to see your dad's reactions to COVID restrictions up close. Tell me about him and how he responded to the public health messaging around the pandemic. This is so funny because my dad is a brilliant person, a clinical psychologist for, gosh, 40, 50 years. Wow. Really, really smart guy and somebody who I look up to tremendously.
所以你近距离观察了你父亲对新冠限制措施的反应。告诉我关于他以及他是如何回应围绕疫情的公共卫生信息的。这太有趣了，因为我父亲是一个聪明人，做了 40、50 年的临床心理学家。哇。非常非常聪明的人，也是我非常敬仰的人。
He also has this side of him that is a very resistant to the kind of messaging or restrictions that we all were having to follow at the beginning of COVID there. So my dad feels so, I think, affronted by what's going on in the world that he decides, well, I gotta get my autonomy back somehow. And the ways that he did it were so fascinating. So he decided, he would go out for drives. He decided to take these little trips, you know?
他也有非常抗拒我们在新冠初期必须遵守的那种信息或限制的一面。所以我父亲觉得，我想，被世界上发生的事情冒犯了，他决定，好吧，我必须以某种方式找回我的自主权。他这样做的方式太迷人了。所以他决定，他会开车出去。他决定进行这些小旅行，你知道吗？
And it's like, I didn't even think he went in anywhere. I don't think he went to a store. I don't think he went to see buddies. I don't think he went to see buddies. Like I think he literally just take his car out and you know drive around the neighborhood or drive to the places he used to go because he wanted to do something. He wanted to feel like he was able to do something when we weren't able really to do anything. And you know the other funny way we saw this play out is we were sort of potted with my parents at the time.
而且就像，我甚至不认为他去了任何地方。我不认为他去了商店。我不认为他去见朋友。我不认为他去见朋友。就像我认为他只是开车出去，你知道在社区里转转，或者开车去他以前去过的地方，因为他想做点什么。当我们在现实中什么都做不了的时候，他想感觉自己能够做点什么。你知道我们看到这种情况发生的另一种有趣的方式是，当时我们和父母住在一起。
And so we would act basically normally with them. But my sister and her husband also live in the area. And my dad, I think, found it really hard to follow the guidelines when we saw them. And so he'd find these little ways to sort of enact his freedom. And he would like, you know, when we saw them, he like wouldn't wear a mask for a little while. He'd like see how long he could push it, or he'd like, you know, kind of go over and give her a hug and a kiss on the forehead when really we're trying to,
所以我们基本上和他们正常相处。但我姐姐和她丈夫也住在该地区。我想我父亲发现当我们见到他们时很难遵守指导方针。所以他会找到这些小方法来实施他的自由。他会，你知道，当我们见到他们时，他有一段时间不戴口罩。他会看看他能坚持多久，或者他会，你知道，走过去给她一个拥抱和额头上的吻，而实际上我们正试图，
you know, stay six feet apart or whatever. So he'd find these little kind of nuggets of ways to try to enact some modicum of autonomy. modicum of autonomy. When we come back, the many strange ways in which our drive for autonomy can keep us from doing what's best for us. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
你知道，保持六英尺的距离等等。所以他会找到这些小方法来尝试实施一点点自主权。一点点自主权。当我们回来时，我们对自主权的渴望可能阻碍我们做最适合我们的事情的许多奇怪方式。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是 Shankar Vedantam。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是 Shankar Vedantam。
No matter our age or where we live in the world or what we do for work, we've all experienced what it's like to have people reject our requests, to be told that what we want is unfair or heavy-handed. And we've all been in the opposite position as well, finding ourselves pushing back against requests that infringe on our autonomy. At Dominican University, Ben Rosenberg has long been fascinated by these acts of rebellion, what psychologists call reactants. Ben, tell me about the work of Jack Brehm. So Jack Brehm originated this idea about psychological reactants,
无论我们的年龄、居住地或工作是什么，我们都经历过被别人拒绝请求，被告知我们想要的东西是不公平或专横的。我们也都在相反的位置上，发现自己抵制那些侵犯我们自主权的请求。在道明尼大学，Ben Rosenberg 长期以来一直对这些反叛行为着迷，心理学家称之为“心理抗拒”。Ben，告诉我 Jack Brehm 的工作。所以 Jack Brehm 发起了这个关于心理抗拒的想法，
and he writes this book in 1966 that is steeped in a lot of other classical social psychological work in the time. So Jack Brehm actually studied with Leon Festinger, who created cognitive dissonance theory. People don't like inconsistency in their lives and so you know cognitive dissonance is all about inconsistency between belief and action and that doesn't make us feel good. Reactance is kind of a similar idea and so Dr. Brem,
他在 1966 年写了这本书，书中浸透了当时许多其他经典的社会心理学工作。所以 Jack Brehm 实际上和 Leon Festinger 一起学习，后者创立了认知失调理论。人们不喜欢生活中的不一致，所以你知道认知失调就是关于信念和行动之间的不一致，这让我们感觉不好。抗拒是一种类似的想法，所以 Brem 博士，
Jack Brem writes this book, it's very skinny but incredibly well-written, fascinating book laying out his ideas about what happens when people's freedom is either threatened or removed. What happens to us when we have autonomy either taken away from us entirely or we feel like something is providing an impingement or an affront on our perceived autonomy. So we're going to talk a little bit about psychological reactants and some of the problems of psychological reactants, but it might be good to start with why we have reactants in the first place. Jack Brehm and others argued that in some ways this is part of our drive for self-determination, which in and of itself is not a bad thing.
Jack Brem 写了这本书，它非常薄但写得非常好，是一本迷人的书，阐述了他关于当人们的自由受到威胁或被剥夺时会发生什么的观点。当我们完全被剥夺了自主权，或者我们觉得有什么东西在侵犯或冒犯我们感知的自主权时，我们会发生什么？所以我们要谈谈心理抗拒以及心理抗拒的一些问题，但从为什么我们首先会有抗拒开始可能比较好。Jack Brehm 和其他人认为，在某种程度上，这是我们自我决定驱动力的一部分，这本身并不是一件坏事。
Absolutely. And you know, I think Brehm actually argued this in his original work that psychological reactants is at least in part evolutionary in nature, that having the ability to choose how we fulfill our various needs is something that allows us to survive and thrive. And so he, and this is before the explosion in evolutionary psychology, he's really making this linkage between freedom and our ability to thrive and to be able to live the lives that we'd like to live.
绝对。而且你知道，我认为 Brehm 在他最初的工作中实际上争辩说，心理抗拒至少部分是进化性质的，拥有选择我们如何满足各种需求的能力是让我们生存和繁荣的东西。所以他，这还是在进化心理学爆发之前，他真的在自由和我们繁荣的能力以及能够过上我们想要的生活的能力之间建立了这种联系。
So, psychologists have explored the many different ways in which people try to reassert their autonomy when someone tries to take it away. Basically, people are saying, you know, you're not the boss of me, effectively, when they're, you know, feeling psychological reactants. One such response is called the boomerang effect. What is the boomerang effect, Ben?
所以，心理学家探索了当有人试图夺走人们的自主权时，人们试图重新主张自主权的许多不同方式。基本上，当人们感到心理抗拒时，他们实际上是在说，你知道，你不是我的老板。一种这样的反应被称为“回旋镖效应”。什么是回旋镖效应，Ben？
This is the classic psychological reactance response. So the boomerang is when somebody tells you to do something or to not do something and you do the exact opposite. Right? So this is me telling my son, hey, you can't have another cookie, you've already had seven, and him going and grabbing the entire package of cookies and eating all of them at the same time. I want to play some tape for you. This is CBS basketball commentator Gary Parrish talking about how during the COVID pandemic, National Basketball Association player Rudy Gobert responded to public health restrictions while doing press conferences with reporters who were positioned at least six feet away.
这是经典的心理抗拒反应。所以回旋镖就是当有人告诉你做某事或不要做某事时，你做了完全相反的事情。对吧？所以这就是我告诉我的儿子，嘿，你不能再吃饼干了，你已经吃了七块了，而他去抓了整包饼干并同时把它们全部吃掉。我想为你播放一些录音。这是 CBS 篮球评论员 Gary Parrish 谈论在新冠疫情期间，美国国家篮球协会球员 Rudy Gobert 如何在面对至少保持六英尺距离的记者进行新闻发布会时回应公共卫生限制。
And so people put mics on the table in front of Rudy Gobert and from a distance you ask your questions, he answers them. And then it's all captured on video. Before he leaves the media room that he was in, he makes a point to touch every microphone, like almost mocking the idea that this is happening and he's having to deal with it in this way. And then of course, not long later, he is diagnosed with coronavirus and the entire NBA is shut down. So I have to say, Ben, this sounds like the boomerang effect in action. Yeah. So my recollection was, you know, he's being asked all these questions about what's going to happen to the NBA, the league's going to shut down, all this stuff, and it's quite uncertain at this point.
所以人们把麦克风放在 Rudy Gobert 面前的桌子上，你从远处问你的问题，他回答它们。然后这一切都被视频捕捉到了。在他离开他所在的媒体室之前，他特意触摸了每一个麦克风，就像嘲笑这件事正在发生，他不得不以这种方式处理它。然后当然，没过多久，他就被诊断出患有冠状病毒，整个 NBA 被关闭。所以我不得不说，Ben，这听起来像是行动中的回旋镖效应。是的。所以我的记忆是，你知道，他被问到所有关于 NBA 会发生什么的问题，联盟要关闭，所有这些事情，此时非常不确定。
And the rumor, at least, was that he licked one of the microphones, sort of on the way out. And again, I find that so funny, but at the same time, it makes a lot of sense. Like his and all the other players' livelihood and the thing they care the most about perhaps is being threatened. They don't know what's gonna happen, right? It's possible at that point that everything will shut down, which of course it did,
而且传言至少是，他在离开时舔了其中一个麦克风。再说一次，我觉得这太搞笑了，但同时，这很有道理。就像他和所有其他球员的生计以及他们可能最关心的事情正受到威胁。他们不知道会发生什么，对吧？当时有可能一切都会关闭，当然确实如此，
but he's feeling this reactance response. He's like, oh my God, I gotta do something to get my freedom back. Yeah. I understand that researchers in North Carolina once carried out a study that looked at college students Alcohol consumption when the legal drinking age in the state was raised from 18 to 21 So students between the ages of 18 and 20 had previously been able to drink legally and then that freedom was taken away What happened then?
但他感到了这种抗拒反应。他就像，哦天哪，我必须做点什么来找回我的自由。是的。我了解到北卡罗来纳州的研究人员曾经进行了一项研究，观察当该州的法定饮酒年龄从 18 岁提高到 21 岁时大学生的酒精消费情况。所以 18 到 20 岁的学生以前能够合法饮酒，然后那种自由被剥夺了。那时发生了什么？
legally, and then that freedom was taken away. What happened, Ben? This is a classic study. And so the folks who are affected by the change in this law responded differently. They wanted to drink more. They did drink more. They were the ones who experienced reactance to the change in the law. And to take us back to something we just talked about, I think this really illustrates the importance of vested interest or stake or importance in arousing psychological reactants, right? The folks who weren't affected by the law, like whatever, they don't care, it's not affecting
合法，然后那种自由被剥夺了。发生了什么，Ben？这是一项经典研究。受法律变化影响的人们反应不同。他们想喝更多。他们确实喝了更多。他们是那些对法律变化经历抗拒的人。为了回到我们刚才谈论的事情，我认为这真正说明了利益相关或重要性在激发心理抗拒方面的重要性，对吧？那些不受法律影响的人，就像随便吧，他们不在乎，它没有影响
me. But the people that this directly impacted, who particularly who became newly illegal to drink were like, whoa, this is an impingement on my freedom. I gotta do something to get this back. One of the points that Jack Brim makes is that when people have freedom or have autonomy in some realm, they become very protective of it if that freedom or autonomy is taken away.
我。但那些直接受到影响的人，特别是那些新变成非法饮酒的人，就像，哇，这是对我自由的侵犯。我必须做点什么来找回这个。Jack Brim 提出的观点之一是，当人们在某个领域拥有自由或自主权时，如果那种自由或自主权被剥夺，他们会变得非常保护它。
So it's one thing not to have freedom in the first place, but when you've had a freedom and then it's taken away, that feels especially painful? Absolutely. And so these are, again, folks who have done this behavior, right? This is clearly to them a free behavior. And, you know, we've... many of us have been college students. We know that drinking, for many people,
所以首先没有自由是一回事，但当你拥有了自由然后它被剥夺了，那感觉特别痛苦？绝对。所以这些，再说一次，是做过这种行为的人，对吧？这对他们来说显然是一种自由行为。而且，你知道，我们……我们许多人都做过大学生。我们知道饮酒，对许多人来说，
is a big part of being a college student. So this is clearly something that's central to their identity. It's part of their college experience. So to have it and have it entirely removed in that fashion, it makes perfect sense, right? Thinking of it from a reactant's perspective, it makes perfect sense that that would be their response. This is, to use your word from earlier, a perfect illustration of a boomerang effect. Boomerang Effect.
是作为大学生的一大部分。所以这显然是他们身份的核心。这是他们大学经历的一部分。所以拥有它并以那种方式完全剥夺它，这完全有道理，对吧？从抗拒的角度来看，他们的反应完全有道理。这，用你早些时候的话说，是回旋镖效应的完美例证。回旋镖效应。
I understand that you yourself have experienced the Boomerang Effect as a dog owner. Oh gosh, yes. So I am oddly a very relaxed, calm person, but at the same time, certain things really make me reactant. And so one of those things for whatever reason, certain things really make me reactant. And so one of those things for whatever reason are restrictions on off-leash dogs. And we have a very well-trained dog who I like to take off-leash with me everywhere.
我了解到你自己作为狗主人也经历过回旋镖效应。哦天哪，是的。所以我奇怪地是一个非常放松、冷静的人，但同时，某些事情真的让我产生抗拒。所以其中一件事不管出于什么原因，某些事情真的让我产生抗拒。所以其中一件事不管出于什么原因是对无绳狗的限制。而且我们有一只训练有素的狗，我喜欢带她到处无绳。
So any sign that says all dogs must be on leash at a park or wherever you are makes me extremely reactant. Give me some examples of how this has manifested. I understand that where you live now in Berkeley, the flouting of rules is almost never a problem, but when you lived in LA, the vibe was somewhat different. Yeah, so in Berkeley, people have dogs off leash everywhere. I go running with the dog off leash. Every park that we take the dog to has a sign that says, dogs must be on leash.
所以任何写着所有狗必须在公园或任何地方拴绳的标志都会让我极其抗拒。给我一些例子说明这是如何表现出来的。我了解到你现在住的伯克利，无视规则几乎从来不是问题，但当你住在洛杉矶时，氛围有些不同。是的，所以在伯克利，人们到处都有无绳狗。我带着狗无绳跑步。我们带狗去的每个公园都有一个标志，写着，狗必须拴绳。
And there's like 50 dogs there off leash. Police drive by, nobody cares. As you said, we lived in Los Angeles for a long time and we lived right across the street from a park. Seemed like a logical place to take dogs off leash. We'd go to the park in the afternoon, people would be congregating with their dogs and it was like being at a keg party when you're underage. Like somebody be on lookout for the cops to drive by And as soon as a cop would drive by like everybody would find their dog put them on leash and scatter her And it's just a wild experience
而且那里有 50 只狗无绳。警察开车经过，没人关心。正如你所说，我们在洛杉矶住了很长时间，我们住在公园对面。看起来是一个带狗无绳的合乎逻辑的地方。我们下午去公园，人们会带着他们的狗聚集在一起，就像未成年时参加酒会一样。就像有人会留意警察开车经过，一旦警察开车经过，每个人都会找到他们的狗，给它们拴上绳子并散开。这真是一次疯狂的经历。
So adjacent to this park there was a tennis court fully fenced tennis court I Figured and you know again. I'm trying to flout these rules because you know reactants. I figured court, fully fenced tennis court. I figured, and again, I'm trying to flout these rules because, you know, reactants, I figured it's fully fenced. I can take my dog in here. So one morning before I go to work, before I go teach, I take the dog in there to throw the ball for her a little bit, you know, she needs to run around. She's a puppy at the time.
所以在这个公园旁边有一个网球场，完全围起来的网球场。我想，你知道，再说一次，我正试图无视这些规则，因为你知道，抗拒。我想，完全围起来的网球场。我想，再说一次，我正试图无视这些规则，因为你知道，抗拒，我想它是完全围起来的。我可以带我的狗进去。所以有一天早上在我去工作之前，在我去教书之前，我带狗进去给她扔球，你知道，她需要跑来跑去。她当时是一只小狗。
She needs lots of exercise. So I'm in the midst of throwing the ball, and a policeman, and we're not talking like a security guard or true policeman from the area where he lived pulls up to the tennis court and basically comes in and says I'm so sorry sir you have to put your dog on leash. A neighbor called and reported that you have your dog off leash in the tennis court. And I'm thinking to myself and I actually said to the policeman who was quite nice I said look like I need her to run around somewhere
她需要大量的运动。所以我正在扔球，一个警察，我们不是在谈论保安或他居住地区的真正警察，开车来到网球场，基本上进来并说我非常抱歉先生你必须给你的狗拴上绳子。邻居打电话报告说你在网球场里没给狗拴绳。我心想，我实际上对那个相当友好的警察说，我说看，我需要她到处跑跑，
I can't go to the park. This is fully fenced like we're not harming anybody by doing this Nobody's using this court at the time. It's like mid-morning and he says, you know, I'm just doing my job I'm so sorry. You're gonna have to get out of here. So whatever I pack up the dog walk across the street to go home You can take a guess as to what I did the next day Which of course was go back to the tennis court and let the dog run around off leash again. I didn't get caught that time, but I was like, you know what?
我不能去公园。这是完全围起来的，我们这样做没有伤害任何人。当时没有人使用这个球场。就像上午中旬，他说，你知道，我只是在做我的工作，我很抱歉。你得离开这里。所以不管怎样，我收拾好狗，走过马路回家。你可以猜猜我第二天做了什么，当然就是回到网球场，再次让狗无绳跑来跑去。我那次没被抓住，但我当时想，你知道吗？
Screw that guy. I'm going back. So besides the boomerang effect, reactants can sometimes change how people evaluate products or activities. The city of Miami once banned phosphate laundry detergents because they were bad for the environment. But researchers then tracked how folks in Miami came to think of phosphate laundry detergents compared to people in other cities in Florida. Right. So the people in Miami who'd had the use of phosphate detergents banned come to like them more, right?
去他的。我要回去。所以除了回旋镖效应，抗拒有时会改变人们评估产品或活动的方式。迈阿密市曾经禁止磷酸盐洗衣粉，因为它们对环境有害。但研究人员随后追踪了迈阿密的人们如何看待磷酸盐洗衣粉，与佛罗里达州其他城市的人们相比。对。所以迈阿密那些被禁止使用磷酸盐洗涤剂的人开始更喜欢它们，对吧？
They come to rate them more positively and again This is another classic reactants finding that when you've restricted somebody's freedom to choose to do something Particularly as you mentioned before something they had done in the past, right? These are folks who'd had the ability to use whatever detergent they wanted, that their response is going to be quite profound. And in this case, they're like, no, no, no, no, no, give me the thing. I like that thing. Give it back to me. I want it.
他们开始更积极地评价它们，再说一次，这是另一个经典的抗拒发现，当你限制了某人做某事的自由，特别是正如你之前提到的，他们过去做过的事情，对吧？这些是曾经有能力使用他们想要的任何洗涤剂的人，他们的反应将是非常深刻的。在这种情况下，他们就像，不，不，不，不，不，给我那个东西。我喜欢那个东西。把它还给我。我想要它。
So this, to me, highlights exactly what you said. We often conceive of reactants as this boomerang effect. I'm doing something to get back my freedom. But there's really another suite of responses that people can have, one of which is this attitudinal response. This like, well, if I can't have this thing, I'm going to really come to like it. Like, I really want this now
所以这对我来说，突出了你所说的。我们经常把抗拒设想为这种回旋镖效应。我正在做某事来找回我的自由。但实际上还有另一套人们可以有的反应，其中之一就是这种态度反应。就像，好吧，如果我不能拥有这个东西，我真的会开始喜欢它。就像，我现在真的很想要这个，
that you've told me I can't have it. And of course, maybe, you know, a week before the ban, people aren't even aware of what's in their laundry detergent, but now you tell them I'm taking it away, suddenly people say, I really like in their laundry detergent, but now you tell them I'm taking it away, suddenly people say, I really like my phosphate laundry detergents. Yeah, exactly. So this makes it so salient to people that,
既然你告诉我我不能拥有它。当然，也许，你知道，在禁令前一周，人们甚至不知道他们的洗衣粉里有什么，但现在你告诉我我要把它拿走，突然人们说，我真的很喜欢我的磷酸盐洗衣粉。是的，完全正确。所以这让人们非常明显地感觉到，
whoa, wait a minute, I could do whatever I wanted in this regard before, and now you're telling me I can't? No, that's not how this thing is going to work. Another way reactants can manifest itself is that people get angry at the individual or institution that is restricting them. Sociologists have found that when a government officially endorses a religion, people living
哇，等一下，我以前在这方面可以做任何我想做的事，现在你告诉我我不能？不，事情不是这样运作的。抗拒表现出来的另一种方式是人们对限制他们的个人或机构感到愤怒。社会学家发现，当政府正式认可一种宗教时，生活在
in that country may respond by feeling resentment toward that religion because their ability to autonomously choose their own faith has been compromised. Can you talk about this idea that one more manifestation of reactance is just we get really mad at the people who are trying to take our autonomy away? This study was so cool and we came across this study, we were asked to write a chapter about reactance in religion, which was like totally out of my comfort zone and my co-authors comfort zone. But it took us into this entirely different literature, right, you can see how well, and this is from a huge sample,
那个国家的人们可能会通过对那种宗教感到怨恨来回应，因为他们自主选择自己信仰的能力受到了损害。你能谈谈这种观点吗，即抗拒的另一种表现仅仅是我们对那些试图夺走我们自主权的人感到非常生气？这项研究太酷了，我们偶然发现了这项研究，我们被要求写一章关于宗教抗拒的内容，这完全超出了我的舒适区和我合著者的舒适区。但这把我们带入了完全不同的文献，对吧，你可以看到，这是来自一个巨大的样本，
how well their data align with reactants predictions that in states that endorse a statewide religion that really threatens people's freedom of choice of how and what they'd like to practice, right? So it makes sense that people living in these kind of places would, as they found in study, report things like less religious attendance and being less highly identified with their religious group. And, you know, you can broaden the scope, I think, of this to think a little bit about other state mandated or kind of county, you know, school-wide mandated things where mandating something in this way
他们的数据与抗拒预测的一致性有多好，在认可全州宗教的州，这确实威胁了人们选择如何以及想要实践什么的自由，对吧？所以生活在这些地方的人们，正如他们在研究中发现的那样，报告诸如较少的宗教出席率和对他们的宗教团体认同度较低之类的事情是有道理的。而且，你知道，我认为你可以扩大这个范围，去思考一点关于其他州强制或某种县，你知道，学校强制的事情，以这种方式强制某事
often has the opposite effect, right? It drives people away from whatever you're trying to mandate them to do. So closer to home, Ben, I understand that you found that your five-year-old son responds in a distinctive way when you try to set limits on his freedom. Can you give me some examples of what he does? I wish I could tell you about times when I didn't arouse reactants in my in my son The best thing to me about thinking about reactants in kids is that so many of kids responses are not commensurate What what you've been asking them to do right and so they have these outlandish responses
通常有相反的效果，对吧？它把人们从你试图强制他们做的事情中推开。所以离家更近一点，Ben，我了解到你发现你五岁的儿子当你试图限制他的自由时，会以一种独特的方式回应。你能给我一些他做的例子吗？我真希望我能告诉你我没有在我的儿子身上激发抗拒的时候。关于思考孩子身上的抗拒，对我来说最好的一点是，很多孩子的反应是不相称的，
To our seemingly benign requests of them So for example, I was asking my son the other day to put on socks before school. A seemingly reasonable request. And so I asked him this question like, you know, 15 times. And finally he's like, I've had enough, Dad, you know, this is making me extremely reactant. And he launches his socks and his shoes, which luckily were, you know, rubber crocs, so not, weren't gonna hurt anybody, launches them at me. And I'm like, okay, dude, I get it. You're reacting so badly to me asking you to put socks on. And I'm assuming this must be the case when you're trying to tell him to get to bed or
你一直要求他们做的事情，对吧？所以他们对我们看似良性的请求有这些古怪的反应。所以例如，我前几天要求我儿子在上学前穿上袜子。一个看似合理的请求。所以我问了他这个问题，就像，你知道，15 次。最后他就像，我受够了，爸爸，你知道，这让我极其抗拒。他把他的袜子和鞋子扔向我，幸运的是，你知道，是橡胶洞洞鞋，所以不会伤害任何人。我就像，好吧，伙计，我明白了。你对我要求你穿袜子反应这么大。而且我假设当你试图告诉他上床睡觉或
restrict the amount of candy he's eating. I mean, anything and everything. This is a common occurrence. We're at the park, which of course he's having fun. He's riding his scooter. And I'm like, dude, we got to go help mom with dinner. Like, you know, we gotta go, we're already running late. And so I'm asking and asking and asking him, and he just perceives this as such an impingement on his freedom to stay and hang out at the park. And he goes, you are the worst daddy in the world, which like, of course I know he doesn't really believe, right?
限制他吃的糖果数量时，情况一定也是这样。我的意思是，任何事情和所有事情。这是一个常见的发生。我们在公园，他当然玩得很开心。他在骑滑板车。我就像，伙计，我们得去帮妈妈做晚饭。就像，你知道，我们得走了，我们已经迟到了。所以我一直在问他，问他，他只是认为这是对他留在公园闲逛的自由的侵犯。他说，你是世界上最糟糕的爸爸，这就像，当然我知道他并不真的相信，对吧？
But it's like, we talk in reactants about source derogation, like, you like, of course I know he doesn't really believe, right? But it's like, we talk in Reactance about source derogation, like, you know, talking crap about the source of the restriction. And it was like, whoa, he's really derogating the source in this case. So you explained that one of the things that drives reactants is how much we care about the thing where we feel our autonomy is being threatened. Another factor that influences the intensity of our reactants has to do with our perceptions of the intent of the authority figure who is restricting our freedom. Can you explain this idea, Ben? Absolutely.
但这就像，我们在抗拒中谈论来源贬损，就像，你知道，当然我知道他并不真的相信，对吧？但这就像，我们在抗拒中谈论来源贬损，就像，你知道，谈论限制来源的垃圾话。就像，哇，他真的在贬损这种情况下的来源。所以你解释说，驱动抗拒的事情之一是我们有多在乎我们觉得自主权受到威胁的事情。影响我们抗拒强度的另一个因素与我们对限制我们自由的权威人物意图的感知有关。你能解释这个想法吗，Ben？绝对。
And importantly, I would say it doesn't even have to be an authority figure. I think this is one of the reactance theory propositions that I find has the most implications. Because if you think about it, almost any of our social interactions have some component of persuasion, right? We're trying to get people to believe what we believe, to go along with us, to comply with what we're asking them. And so the thought is that just perceiving, just my thinking, wait a minute, is Shankar trying to persuade me to do something or act in a certain way?
而且重要的是，我会说它甚至不必是权威人物。我认为这是我发现最有影响的抗拒理论命题之一。因为如果你想一想，我们几乎所有的社交互动都有某种说服成分，对吧？我们试图让人们相信我们所相信的，跟随我们，遵守我们要求他们做的事情。所以想法是，仅仅感知，仅仅是我在想，等一下，Shankar 是在试图说服我做某事或以某种方式行事吗？
Just that perception is profound enough of an affront to our freedom to make us be reactant and in turn we're going to push back, right? Either attitudinally or behavioral, we're going to push back against whatever that request is or whatever the persuasion target is. And I guess if we perceive that the person who is trying to influence us, in fact is trying to influence us, in other words they're deliberately trying to change our view about something. I now perceive this as a more direct assault on my autonomy and presumably my reactance is going to be higher.
仅仅那种感知就足以成为对我们自由的深刻冒犯，让我们产生抗拒，反过来我们也会反击，对吧？无论是态度上还是行为上，我们都会反击那个请求或说服目标。而且我想如果我们感知到试图影响我们的人，实际上是在试图影响我们，换句话说，他们是在故意试图改变我们对某事的看法。我现在认为这是对我自主权的更直接的攻击，大概我的抗拒会更高。
100%. If it's really clear that somebody is trying to convince you to believe in their side of a political debate or trying to persuade you to come and eat vegan with them or whatever, if it's really, really evident, then absolutely, the reactance is gonna be higher. And this has been born out in reviews and meta-analyses that have shown like this is quite a strong effect, right? As soon as we perceive somebody's trying to persuade us, particularly in this really strong and
100%。如果很清楚有人试图说服你相信他们那边的政治辩论，或者试图说服你和他们一起吃纯素等等，如果它真的，真的非常明显，那么绝对，抗拒会更高。这已经在评论和荟萃分析中得到了证实，表明这确实是一个很强的效果，对吧？一旦我们感知到有人试图说服我们，特别是在这种非常强烈和
clear way that we are pushing back. We do not like our freedom to be taken away from us in that way. So we've been talking about the various situational factors that can affect the intensity of the psychological reactants we feel. Do you think there might be a gender component to it? I mean, many of the examples of psychological reactants that we've talked about involve men and that might be my stereotype that men are more prone to reactants than women. Is there any truth to that? To be sure, that fits our stereotype.
清晰的方式下，我们就会反击。我们不喜欢我们的自由以那种方式被夺走。所以我们一直在谈论可能影响我们感受到的心理抗拒强度的各种情境因素。你认为可能存在性别成分吗？我的意思是，我们谈论的许多心理抗拒的例子都涉及男性，这可能是我的刻板印象，即男性比女性更容易产生抗拒。这有什么道理吗？可以肯定的是，这符合我们的刻板印象。
And unfortunately, there hasn't been a ton of research on this specific question. And I think my observations certainly align with yours. And there are a few studies out there that would suggest, particularly on trait reactants, which we were just talking about, that men tend to be more prone to reactants in women. But there's also some studies on the other side that show there's no difference.
不幸的是，关于这个具体问题并没有太多的研究。而且我认为我的观察当然与你的相符。有一些研究表明，特别是在特质抗拒方面，我们刚才谈到的，男性往往比女性更容易产生抗拒。但也有一些研究在另一面显示没有区别。
So my observations align with yours. I'm not sure we have the data to claim that that's an evidence-based conclusion. My intuition is that you're probably right though. So as a psychologist who had been studying reactants for years, when the COVID pandemic hit in 2020, you said that the restrictions that were put in place in some ways created a perfect storm in terms of generating psychological reactants. How so Ben? Well, mandating anything is tough, right? Mandating anything you're gonna run into reactants as we've been talking about.
所以我的观察与你的相符。我不确定我们是否有数据声称这是一个基于证据的结论。不过我的直觉是你可能是对的。所以作为一名研究抗拒多年的心理学家，当新冠疫情在 2020 年爆发时，你说所实施的限制在某些方面在产生心理抗拒方面创造了一场完美风暴。怎么说，Ben？好吧，强制任何事情都很困难，对吧？强制任何事情你都会遇到抗拒，正如我们一直在谈论的那样。
You're gonna run into people who say no, no, no, this doesn't apply to me. Quit taking away my freedom of behavior. I'm not gonna do it. I'm not gonna comply. People who say, no, no, no, this doesn't apply to me, quit taking away my freedom of behavior, I'm not gonna do it, I'm not gonna comply. And when you're telling people to wear a mask, they feel, I've been walking around for years without a mask and you're taking away that freedom. When you're asking people to socially distance, people are saying, you're taking my freedom away.
你会遇到一些人，他们会说，不，不，不，这不适用于我。别再剥夺我的行为自由了。我不会照做的。我不会服从的。那些说“不，不，不，这不适用于我，别再剥夺我的行为自由，我不会照做，我不会服从”的人。当你告诉人们戴口罩时，他们会觉得，我多年来一直没戴口罩走来走去，而你却剥夺了那种自由。当你要求人们保持社交距离时，人们会说，你在剥夺我的自由。
You tell people to get vaccinated, people say, you know, it's my body, my choice. And in all of these cases, you really have the same pattern of people feeling like their autonomy is under fire. 100% you do. And if you think back to some of those early recommendations, I remember walking around and seeing signs on stores that said, you must wear a mask to enter. Actually here at Dominican, we had signs on the campus door that said, you must be vaccinated.
你告诉人们去接种疫苗，人们会说，你知道，这是我的身体，我的选择。在所有这些情况下，你实际上都看到了同样的模式，即人们觉得他们的自主权受到了攻击。百分之百是这样。如果你回想一下那些早期的建议，我记得走在街上看到商店里的牌子上写着，进入必须佩戴口罩。事实上，在多米尼加大学，我们的校园门口也贴着牌子，写着必须接种疫苗。
You must wear a mask to enter these buildings. And you know, look, I was following the guidelines as I think most people were, but it's so clear that would be an affront to many people's freedoms, right? To your point, I've gone into stores my whole life without a mask. I've come to work without a mask my whole life. So to feel like you're now telling me what I must do when I come to do these things I've done for many years is a really tough proposition. Yeah, and many people I think responded not just saying, I don't, I don't, I'm not going to follow the rules, but they responded with anger. They responded saying, you know, this is an outrage. Yeah, I mean, you saw that play out, especially with travel, right?
进入这些建筑物必须佩戴口罩。你知道，看，我遵循了指导方针，我想大多数人也是这样，但很明显，这对许多人的自由来说是一种冒犯，对吧？正如你所说，我这辈子进商店都没戴过口罩。我这辈子上班都没戴过口罩。所以，当你现在告诉我，当我来做这些我做了很多年的事情时，我必须做什么，这确实是一个非常艰难的提议。是的，我认为许多人的反应不仅仅是说，我不，我不，我不会遵守规则，而是他们以愤怒作为回应。他们回应说，你知道，这简直是暴行。是的，我的意思是，你看到了这种情况的发生，尤其是在旅行方面，对吧？
I mean, travel, I think, became such a flash point as people were arguing about masking or, you know, not wanting to follow some of these guidelines. And it was like, I remember taking probably my first flight after, you know, sort of post it really was during COVID, 2021 or something. And most people were following the rules, but there were a handful of people that were like, you know, had their mask under their nose or like would take it off to eat something on the plane and then they just would leave it off for a really long time. And it's like, that's a pretty keen way of reasserting your freedom, right? You're wearing your mask in air quotes
我的意思是，我认为旅行成了一个爆发点，因为人们在争论戴口罩，或者，你知道，不想遵循其中一些指导方针。就像，我记得我大概是在新冠疫情期间，2021年左右，第一次坐飞机。大多数人都在遵守规则，但有少数人，你知道，把口罩戴在鼻子下面，或者像是在飞机上吃东西时摘下来，然后就一直不戴。这是一种重新主张你自由的相当敏锐的方式，对吧？你戴着口罩，打着引号。
But you've now just figured out a way to take it off for a little bit and get back some of that autonomy Now it's important to offer a disclaimer or two here, Ben. There are authoritarian regimes that are so powerful that everyone falls in line because they're afraid that they're going to get sent to prison or be shot if they don't comply. But it's also the case that sometimes people embrace authority figures and voluntarily surrender their freedoms. Why would this be the case? So some of the work we've done is actually approach this exact question.
但你现在已经找到了一种方法，可以把它摘下来一会儿，重新获得一些自主权。现在，在这里提供一两个免责声明很重要，本。有些威权政权非常强大，每个人都顺从，因为他们害怕如果不服从就会被送进监狱或被枪毙。但同样的情况是，有时人们会拥护权威人物并自愿放弃他们的自由。为什么会这样呢？所以我们所做的一些工作实际上就是探讨这个问题。
One factor it seems is the level of uncertainty that people feel about their ability to live their lives as they would like. They're uncertain about their future, about their present, where maybe they're gonna feed their family or where they're gonna work. And so in this context, it does seem from some of the work that we've done that when people feel uncertain, they are less reactant to these sort of authoritarian
一个因素似乎是人们对自己能否按照自己想要的方式生活感到不确定。他们对自己的未来、现在感到不确定，也许是关于他们将如何养活家人，或者他们将在哪里工作。因此，在这种背景下，从我们所做的一些工作来看，当人们感到不确定时，他们对这些威权主义的反应似乎较少。
kind of demanding type messages, which I think to your point has some corollaries with these authoritarian regimes, right? So if people that are living under this kind of duress feel uncertain about the future, they feel uncertain about their lives and their ability to handle whatever is coming their way in life, they might be like, you know what? I don't need any freedom. I just need somebody to tell me how to survive, right? And how to kind of get through this feeling, this distinct feeling
那种要求式的消息，我认为这与你提到的威权政权有一些对应关系，对吧？所以，如果生活在这种压力下的人对未来感到不确定，他们对自己的生活以及处理生活中即将到来的一切的能力感到不确定，他们可能会想，你知道吗？我不需要任何自由。我只需要有人告诉我如何生存，对吧？以及如何度过这种感觉，这种独特的感觉。
of uncertainty. You know, I'm thinking about Abraham Maslow's hierarchy of needs pyramid here, and I know that work is somewhat dated and contested today. But if you buy his idea that we have basic needs for food insecurity and then higher needs for autonomy and self-determination. Reactance might be something that's more common at the higher end of the pyramid. When you actually have your basic needs taken care of, now you can get mad at someone if they are hurrying you as you're taking a three-point turn. But for people
关于不确定性。你知道，我在这里想到了亚伯拉罕·马斯洛的需求层次金字塔，我知道这项工作在今天看来有些过时且存在争议。但如果你相信他的观点，即我们有对食物安全的基本需求，然后有对自主权和自我决定的更高需求。抗拒心理可能是金字塔顶端更常见的东西。当你真正满足了基本需求时，如果有人在你进行三点掉头时催促你，你现在可以对他们生气。但对于那些
who have more pressing needs, needs about home and security and safety, is it possible that that's a point where you don't care so much about autonomy? You just care about those basic needs being met? There does seem to be a sort of privilege component, I think, is what you're getting at when you say that, right? Like, yes, I have the privilege to become reactant about a three-point turn, whereas somebody who doesn't know where their next meal is coming from isn't gonna be reactant about the same things. And I wonder if reactance is a core human motivation, but we've primarily only studied it with people that are sort of have the privilege to be reactant to,
有更紧迫需求的人，关于家庭、安全和保障的需求，是否可能在那个时候你就不那么关心自主权了？你只关心那些基本需求得到满足？当你这么说时，我认为这确实有一种特权成分，对吧？就像，是的，我有特权对三点掉头感到抗拒，而一个不知道下一顿饭在哪里的人，就不会对同样的事情感到抗拒。我想知道抗拒心理是否是一种核心的人类动机，但我们主要只研究了那些有特权去抗拒的人，
like some of the classic studies would give people a choice of a painting and then tell them they couldn't have it, right? It's like, that's a very privileged kind of thing, a very privileged way to test that idea. So I wonder how much of it is that we haven't tested it with folks who have somewhat less privilege and how much of it is that we just don't experience it
就像一些经典研究会给人们选择一幅画，然后告诉他们不能拥有它，对吧？这就像，这是一种非常有特权的事情，一种测试这个想法的非常有特权的方式。所以我不知道我们有多少是因为没有在那些特权较少的人群中进行测试，也不知道有多少是因为我们只是没有经历过
to those lesser levels of privilege. When we come back, how to craft messages that are less likely to trigger psychological reactants. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Life offers us many opportunities to learn from others, but lots of us have a contrarian streak and we don't like to be told what to do. If a teacher or a parent or a manager tells us not to do something, we are drawn to doing it.
那些较低水平的特权。当我们回来时，将讨论如何制定不太可能触发心理抗拒的消息。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。生活为我们提供了许多向他人学习的机会，但我们许多人都有反叛的倾向，我们不喜欢被告知该做什么。如果老师、父母或经理告诉我们不要做某事，我们反而会被吸引去做。
At Dominican University in California, psychologist Ben Rosenberg studies the phenomenon of psychological reactants, how we respond with anger or defiance when someone tries to change our behavior. Ben, I understand that one strategy for preventing reactants is to pay attention to the language we use. Researchers once studied the effects of two kinds of anti-drinking messages that were aimed at college students. One set of messages said there was conclusive evidence that drinking was bad and that, quote, any reasonable person must acknowledge these conclusions.
在加利福尼亚的多米尼加大学，心理学家本·罗森伯格研究了心理抗拒现象，即当有人试图改变我们的行为时，我们如何以愤怒或反抗来回应。本，我明白防止抗拒的一种策略是注意我们使用的语言。研究人员曾经研究过针对大学生的两种反饮酒信息的效果。第一组信息说有确凿的证据表明饮酒是有害的，并且引用说，“任何理性的人都必须承认这些结论。”
Others were given the same data about the risks of alcohol, but were told, you may wish to carefully consider the evidence. What were the differences between these messages and how did they go over? So this is a really seminal study in the reactants literature, and it set off a cascade of a new way to study reactants and this messaging context that you mentioned. So one of the messages you briefly summarized had this very strong language, sort of strong-handed,
其他人收到了关于酒精风险的相同数据，但被告知，“你可能希望仔细考虑这些证据。”这些信息之间的区别是什么，它们的效果如何？所以这是抗拒心理文献中一项非常开创性的研究，它引发了一连串研究抗拒心理和这种信息传递背景的新方法。所以你简要总结的其中一条信息有这种非常强烈的语言，某种强硬的，
you know, you must not do this thing, right? The other message is a little bit softer in the way that it's portrayed. And the difference that they find, and it has been found over and over again in the years since, is that people who are exposed to those really strongly worded, those highly controlling messages, have much more reactance to the message
你知道，你必须不能做这件事，对吧？另一条信息在表达方式上稍微柔和一些。他们发现的区别，并且在随后的几年里被反复发现，是那些接触到那些措辞非常强烈、高度控制性信息的人，对信息的抗拒心理要大得多。
than people who are exposed to a slightly more softly worded message, right, that says you should consider or things like that versus the you must kind of wording. And of course, when I'm thinking about the COVID pandemic, you know, what we heard most often was the very strong language, right? We heard mandates. Yeah, and that was one of my biggest critiques, honestly. For a long time, I think it was on a soapbox yelling at no one talking about this. But yeah, that was one of my biggest critiques. It's like we could so easily reduce the amount of freedom threat and amount of reactants
比那些接触到措辞稍微柔和一点的信息的人，对吧，那些说你应该考虑之类的话，而不是你必须之类的措辞。当然，当我想到新冠疫情时，你知道，我们听到最多的是非常强烈的语言，对吧？我们听到了强制令。是的，老实说，这是我最大的批评之一。很长一段时间，我想我是在肥皂箱上对着空气大喊大叫，谈论这个问题。但是的，这是我最大的批评之一。就像我们可以很容易地减少自由威胁的程度和抗拒心理的程度，
that at least many people feel in response to these messages simply by saying it a little bit more softly, right? Not you must wear a mask here, but please consider wearing a mask here, right? Like that comes across so much more differently. It was also the case that sometimes we would hear a recommendation from public health authorities and then that recommendation would change in the following weeks and months. And of course this happened because the situation was highly uncertain and it wasn't entirely clear what we should do. But talk about the effect that this had in terms of psychological reactants. I think this waffling
至少许多人在回应这些信息时感受到的，仅仅是通过稍微柔和一点的方式说出来，对吧？不是你必须在这里戴口罩，而是请考虑在这里戴口罩，对吧？就像那样听起来完全不同。同样的情况是，有时我们会听到公共卫生当局的建议，然后该建议在接下来的几周和几个月里会发生变化。当然，这是因为情况高度不确定，而且完全不清楚我们应该做什么。但谈谈这在心理抗拒方面产生的影响。我认为这种摇摆不定
back and forth between recommendations made it all the more likely that people would be reactant to being told you must do something, right? Last week you told me I must not wear a mask, and now this week you're telling I must wear a mask? Like, where does the answer lie? So it became easier, I think, for a lot of people just to flout all of the recommendations, right? Just to write off all of the recommendations.
在建议之间来回变动，使得人们更有可能对被告知必须做某事产生抗拒，对吧？上周你告诉我必须不戴口罩，现在这周你告诉我必须戴口罩？就像，答案在哪里？所以我认为，对很多人来说，直接无视所有的建议变得更容易了，对吧？直接否定所有的建议。
And it really decreased the amount of, I think, trust and the amount of authority really that the CDC and other messaging, you know, public health messaging organizations had to tell people what to do or to instruct them about what they should be doing. So when you tell people you should consider wearing a mask instead of you must wear a mask, the difference that I'm hearing is that
这确实降低了信任度，也降低了疾控中心和其他公共卫生信息组织告诉人们该做什么或指导他们应该做什么的权威性。所以当你告诉人们你应该考虑戴口罩而不是你必须戴口罩时，我听到的区别是
the low-controlling language underlines and supports people's autonomy. Is that the low controlling language underlines and supports people's autonomy. Is that the idea here, Ben? Absolutely the idea that by not mandating people do something, we're reminding them that ultimately it's up to them, right? And that's actually one of the lines that you'll see in a lot of these more low controlling messages in some of the experimental work. It's like they'll say some stuff about how you should consider this or this,
低控制性的语言强调并支持了人们的自主权。这就是这里的想法吗，本？绝对是这个想法，通过不强制人们做某事，我们在提醒他们，最终决定权在他们自己手中，对吧？这实际上是你在一些实验工作中看到的许多这些低控制性信息中的一行。就像他们会说一些关于你应该考虑这个或那个的话，
and then the last line, and we've used this in some of our studies, the last line is like, but ultimately the choice is yours, right? And so it really puts the onus back on people, it gives them their autonomy back, right? It gives them their freedom to make a decision back, while also informing them of what they should normatively be doing. Another strategy to avoid reactants is to offer people choices.
然后最后一行，我们在我们的一些研究中也用过，最后一行是，但最终选择权在你，对吧？所以它确实把责任放回了人们身上，它给了他们自主权，对吧？它给了他们做决定的自由，同时也告知了他们规范上应该做什么。避免抗拒的另一种策略是提供选择。
One study looked at interventions to protect people from skin cancer. Tell me what the study did and what it found. So in this study, the authors gave people an option saying you could use sunscreen, wear protective clothing, instead of asking people to do both of these things, right? And so giving them a choice, giving them options was enough to reduce the amount of reactants that they experienced in response to the message. And I think this strategy for reactants reduction is particularly applicable, right? Because
一项研究着眼于保护人们免受皮肤癌的干预措施。告诉我这项研究做了什么以及发现了什么。所以在这项研究中，作者给了人们一个选择，说你可以使用防晒霜，穿防护服，而不是要求人们同时做这两件事，对吧？所以给他们一个选择，给他们选项足以减少他们在回应信息时所经历的抗拒程度。我认为这种减少抗拒的策略特别适用，对吧？因为
rather than asking your friend or your kid to do this one particular thing, you might say, hey, how about we do one of these couple of things, right? I think they're going to be more likely to respond in a positive way. There's multiple options for fulfilling this request. I mean, I think that's really what is at the nut of this idea and at the nut of this study is that you have a variety of ways in which you can comply with this request I'm making of you rather than just one. Right. And what I'm taking away from this is that when you give people choices, sometimes you're actually giving people choices, but sometimes perhaps all you're doing is you're giving people the illusion of a
与其要求你的朋友或孩子做这一件特定的事情，你可能会说，嘿，我们做这几件事中的一件怎么样，对吧？我认为他们更有可能以积极的方式回应。有多种选择可以满足这个请求。我的意思是，我认为这确实是这个想法和这项研究的核心，即你有多种方式可以遵守我向你提出的这个请求，而不仅仅是一种。对。我从中得到的是，当你给人们选择时，有时你实际上是在给人们选择，但有时也许你所做的只是给人们一种
choice, but the illusion of a choice gives people the opportunity to exercise a certain degree of autonomy. You know autonomy. I remember when my own child was small, there were some parenting books that recommended giving your child closed options. So you ask the child, would you like to go to sleep in five minutes or 15 minutes? You're not asking the child, would you like to go to bed? Period. You're just saying the options are five minutes, 15 minutes. You have the autonomy to choose.
选择的错觉，但选择的错觉给了人们行使一定程度自主权的机会。你知道自主权。我记得当我自己的孩子还小的时候，有一些育儿书建议给你的孩子封闭式的选项。所以你问孩子，你想在五分钟还是十五分钟后睡觉？你不是在问孩子，你想去睡觉吗？句号。你只是说选项是五分钟，十五分钟。你有选择的自主权。
Yeah. Perfect example, right? So we're not saying, hey, do whatever the heck you want, but we're saying here are some very specific ways in which you can fulfill my request or in which you can comply with what I'm asking you to do that I've chosen, right? I've selected because all of these will meet my aims as the requester, but I know that offering you a handful of ways to do it will reduce the amount of reactance you feel and make it less likely that you're gonna push back
是的。完美的例子，对吧？所以我们不是说，嘿，做任何你想做的事，但我们是说这里有一些非常具体的方式，你可以满足我的请求，或者你可以遵守我要求你做的事情，这些是我选择的，对吧？我选择了，因为所有这些都会达到我作为请求者的目标，但我知道提供给你几种方法来做这件事会减少你感受到的抗拒，并使你不太可能推脱
and not do any of the things I want you to do. So like many aspects of our behavior, one reason reactance might be so powerful is that people are usually not aware that they are behaving reactively. So the parent really does seem like a party pooper to the kid. The manager really does appear clueless to the employee. One way to avert psychological reactants that you and others have studied
而不做任何我想要你做的事情。所以就像我们行为的许多方面一样，抗拒心理之所以如此强大，一个原因通常是人们并没有意识到他们正在表现出抗拒。所以父母在孩子眼里确实看起来像个扫兴的人。经理在员工眼里确实看起来一无所知。你和其他人研究过的避免心理抗拒的一种方法
is to get people to notice that they are experiencing reactants, to warn them ahead of time that they may experience this phenomenon. How would this work, Ben? So these kind of studies are all about inoculation. And I think this is such a fun idea because it inoculates somebody just like a vaccine inoculates us, prepares us for the arrival of some pathogen. And in this case, we're thinking of reactants like a pathogen.
是让人们注意到他们正在经历抗拒，提前警告他们可能会经历这种现象。这怎么起作用，本？所以这类研究都是关于接种的。我认为这是一个非常有趣的想法，因为它像疫苗接种一样给某人接种，为我们准备好应对某种病原体的到来。在这种情况下，我们把抗拒心理看作一种病原体。
So if we tell people, hey, your freedom might be threatened by this thing I'm gonna ask you to do, they tend to respond a little bit more mildly, right? It seems to have the effect of defusing their reactants to whatever your ultimate proposition of them might be. Another interesting technique to circumvent psychological reactants is to frame the request or the advice
所以如果我们告诉人们，嘿，你的自由可能会因为我将要要求你做的事情而受到威胁，他们往往会反应得稍微温和一些，对吧？这似乎有化解他们对你最终向他们提出的任何建议的抗拒的效果。规避心理抗拒的另一种有趣技术是构建请求或建议
in the context of a story rather than in the form of instructions. Explain how this works, Ben. So really, the idea here is twofold. So on the one hand, the narrative story works as a more subtle form of persuasion, right? In the past, earlier on in our conversation, we're talking about this really clear overt kind of persuasion and how that often doesn't work. So if you think about a persuasive message being folded into a story with characters that the audience like or that they care about, they aren't going to notice in the same way that you're
在故事的背景下，而不是以指令的形式。解释一下这是如何工作的，本。所以这里的想法确实是双重的。一方面，叙事故事作为一种更微妙的说服形式，对吧？在过去，在我们谈话的早期，我们谈到了这种非常清晰、公开的说服，以及它通常是如何不起作用的。所以如果你认为说服信息被折叠进一个有观众喜欢或关心的角色的故事中，他们就不会以同样的方式注意到你
trying to persuade them. That perceived persuasive intent that we talked about earlier won't quite be there in the same way. And so the result, hopefully, is that they won't become reactant. Even though you're requesting that they do something, you're trying to persuade them of something, they're not gonna become reactant in the same way because they're not perceiving that it's a persuasive message, they're getting caught up in the story.
试图说服他们。我们之前谈到的那种感知到的说服意图不会以同样的方式存在。所以结果，希望是，他们不会产生抗拒。即使你要求他们做某事，你试图说服他们某事，他们也不会以同样的方式产生抗拒，因为他们没有感觉到这是一个说服信息，他们被故事吸引住了。
And so that by itself, that turning off or turning down that reactance should be enough to get people's attention and allow them to more freely process the message rather than kind of tuning it out. The second part of this is that if the narrative is well done, ideally people will come to identify with the characters in the story. We like to listen to people that we like or who we identify with or who we perceive as
因此，仅仅是那种关闭或调低抗拒心理，就应该足以引起人们的注意，并让他们更自由地处理信息，而不是将其屏蔽。这部分的第二点是，如果叙事做得好，理想情况下人们会认同故事中的角色。我们喜欢听我们喜欢的人，或者我们认同的人，或者我们认为
being similar to. And so that kind of getting folded up, getting caught up in that narrative can also increase persuasion and reduce reactants. You say, Ben, that we can also leverage the power of psychological reactants for good. How do we do that? This is such a cool and innovative approach, and I liken it in some ways to reverse psychology. So most of the time, you know, we're thinking reactants bad, right? We want to avoid it.
相似的人。所以那种被折叠进去，被卷入叙事中也可以增加说服力并减少抗拒。你说，本，我们也可以利用心理抗拒的力量来做好事。我们怎么做呢？这是一种非常酷和创新的方法，我在某些方面把它比作逆向心理学。所以大多数时候，你知道，我们认为抗拒心理是不好的，对吧？我们想避免它。
What if, and this was originally kind of pioneered by Brian Quick and colleagues. And so Brian had this idea of like, well, what if we make the thing that we want people not to do the source of the freedom threat? So if we make, say, and they were studying in particular, anti-smoking, right, and trying to get people not to smoke. So they framed in their study secondhand smoke as being a freedom threat.
如果，这最初是由布莱恩·奎克和同事开创的。所以布莱恩有这样一个想法，好吧，如果我们把我们想要人们不做的事情变成自由威胁的来源呢？所以如果我们制造，比如，他们特别研究的是反吸烟，对吧，试图让人们不吸烟。所以他们在研究中把二手烟构建为一种自由威胁。
They convinced people, they were trying to persuade people to be pro smoking regulations. So they made secondhand smoke the freedom threat. And this was the thing that they're trying to reduce, right? So they said, look, if secondhand smoke is threatening your freedom to breathe clean air and act in the way you'd like and going the places that you would like, it turns out that people come to
他们说服人们，他们试图说服人们支持吸烟法规。所以他们把二手烟变成了自由威胁。这就是他们试图减少的东西，对吧？所以他们说，看，如果二手烟正在威胁你呼吸新鲜空气、按照你想要的方式行事以及去你想去的地方的自由，事实证明人们开始
perceive secondhand smoke as a freedom threat and they show that they come to support clean air policies, right? So it's really, it's turning the idea of reactants on its head. After all these years of research, do you feel like you've gotten better and more skilled at not eliciting reactants from others? I would like to think so. I've at the very least, if not gotten better, I've at the very least become more aware of the kinds of approaches that will arouse reactants in other people.
感知到二手烟是一种自由威胁，他们表现出他们开始支持清洁空气政策，对吧？所以这确实是把抗拒心理的想法颠倒过来了。经过这么多年的研究，你觉得你是否变得更好、更擅长不引起他人的抗拒了？我愿意这样认为。我至少，如果不是变得更好，我至少变得更了解那些会在其他人身上引起抗拒的方法。
The ways that I frame questions or requests to other people. That's not to say that I can entirely avoid it. Certainly in situations with my son, who again is five and a half, I find myself saying, you know, you have to do this, you must do this, and immediately think to myself, that's not the right way to frame that, right?
我向他人提出问题或请求的方式。这并不是说我可以完全避免它。当然，在我五岁半的儿子的处境中，我发现自己会说，你知道，你必须做这个，你必须做这个，然后立刻对自己想，那不是构建它的正确方式，对吧？
So I think if nothing else, it's made me much more aware of the ways in which our normal day-to-day conversations, as well as bigger requests, can elicit this reactance response, can make people feel like their freedom is impinged. And really that we should try as best we can in those interactions,
所以我认为至少，它让我更加意识到我们正常的日常对话，以及更大的请求，可以引起这种抗拒反应，可以让人们觉得他们的自由受到了侵犯。而且确实，我们应该在这些互动中尽我们所能，
particularly with people who we care about and that we love, to frame things in a way that's gonna make make them feel autonomous, that's going to make them feel like they have volition rather than impinging upon their freedom. Ben, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me, Shankar. If you have follow-up questions for Ben Rosenberg that you'd be willing to share with members of the Hidden Brain audience, please find a quiet room and record a voice memo and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. 60 seconds
特别是与我们关心和爱的人，以一种让他们感到自主的方式来构建事情，让他们觉得他们有意志，而不是侵犯他们的自由。本，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你的邀请，尚卡尔。如果你有后续问题想问本·罗森伯格，并且愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享，请找一个安静的房间录制语音备忘录，并发送电子邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。那个电子邮件地址再次是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。60秒
is plenty and please use the subject line reactants. If you want to write out a question, please be sure to tell us how to pronounce your name. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brainins executive editor. We end today with a story from our sister show, My Unsung Hero.
足够了，请使用主题行“抗拒”。如果你想写下一个问题，请务必告诉我们如何发音你的名字。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天以来自我们的姐妹节目《我未被歌颂的英雄》的一个故事结束。
This My Unsung Hero segment is brought to you by Discover. Our story comes from Moss Masumoto. Growing up, Moss was vaguely aware that he had an aunt who had been separated from the family in the 1940s. Her name was Shizuko Sugimoto. Shizuko had an intellectual disability, and as was often done in those days, she became a ward of the state. The family never talked about her and assumed she had passed away.
这个《我未被歌颂的英雄》片段由 Discover 赞助。我们的故事来自莫斯·马苏莫托。在成长过程中，莫斯模糊地意识到他有一个在 20 世纪 40 年代与家人失散的姑姑。她的名字叫静子杉本。静子有智力障碍，正如当时经常做的那样，她成为了国家的监护对象。家人从不谈论她，并以为她已经去世了。
But one day in 2012, Moss got a surprising message from a funeral home worker named Renee Johnson. She was helping to plan the funeral of a woman in hospice, a woman named Shizuko Sugimoto. Shizuko was in her 90s. So she looked up in the 1930 census, found Shizuko's name with my mom's name, and proceeded to phone me so Shizuko would not die alone. It was amazing for Renee to go through all that work when she didn't have to. Because she got the contract for this Shizuko Sugimoto, who had no family apparently on the records, and they were just going to take care
但 2012 年的一天，莫斯收到了来自一位名叫蕾妮·约翰逊的殡仪馆工作人员的令人惊讶的消息。她正在帮助计划一位在临终关怀院的女性的葬礼，一位名叫静子杉本的女性。静子已经 90 多岁了。所以她查阅了 1930 年的人口普查，找到了静子的名字和我妈妈的名字，并打电话给我，这样静子就不会孤独地死去。蕾妮在不需要的情况下做所有这些工作真是太棒了。因为她接到了这个静子杉本的合同，记录上显然没有家人，他们只是要照顾
of the body and she would pass away in a very simple way. But it was Renee who said no, she wanted to see if family could be reunited with this person. When I told my mom and my aunt and uncle, I said, okay, I want you to sit down because I have this news. And I said, you remember Aunt Shishako? And they all said, oh yeah, yeah, she passed away a long time ago. And I took a deep breath and I said, no, Shishako's alive.
遗体，她会以一种非常简单的方式去世。但正是蕾妮说不，她想看看家人是否能与这个人团聚。当我告诉我的妈妈、姑姑和叔叔时，我说，好吧，我希望你们坐下来，因为我有这个消息。我说，你们还记得静子姑姑吗？他们都说，哦，是的，是的，她很久以前就去世了。我深吸了一口气说，不，静子还活着。
And then everyone said, no, that can't be. That can't be right. And then I told them the story of what happened. And they all paused and said, we need to see her. We need to go see her. Renee opened the door to a family secret, and especially dealing with someone with a disability, and in this case, an intellectual disability.
然后每个人都说，不，那不可能。那不可能是对的。然后我告诉了他们发生的事情的故事。他们都停顿了一下说，我们需要见她。我们需要去见她。蕾妮打开了家庭秘密的大门，特别是处理有残疾的人，在这种情况下，是智力障碍。
For my parents' generation and grandparents, this was a secret that people had, and it brought shame to a lot of people. And people were treated wrongly by becoming invisible and hiding these kind of facts. So, Renee, I want to thank you for opening the door for our family to explore this traumatic history that's full of choices and circumstances beyond control. We were forced to reexamine and probe our own family secrets, and I want to thank you
对于我父母那一代和祖父母那一代，这是一个人们拥有的秘密，它给很多人带来了耻辱。人们因为变得隐形和隐藏这些事实而受到错误的对待。所以，蕾妮，我要感谢你为我们家庭打开了大门，去探索这段充满选择和超出控制范围的情况的创伤历史。我们被迫重新审视和探究我们自己的家庭秘密，我要感谢你
for that because you have changed our family history and also opened my own eyes to understand this is part of the legacy that I carry and all thanks to you. Mas Masumoto of Delray, California. The family did get to meet Shizuko, who lived another two years after they reunited. This segment of My Unsung Hero was brought to you by Discover. Discover believes everyone deserves to feel special and celebrates those who exhibit the spirit in their
因为你改变了我们的家庭历史，也打开了我的眼睛，让我明白这是我所承载的遗产的一部分，这一切都归功于你。加利福尼亚州德尔雷的莫斯·马苏莫托。家人确实见到了静子，她在团聚后又活了两年。《我未被歌颂的英雄》的这一片段由 Discover 赞助。Discover 相信每个人都值得感到特别，并赞美那些在他们的
communities. I'm a long-standing card member myself. Learn more at discover.com slash credit card. For more Hidden Brain be sure to check out our free newsletter. In every issue we bring you the latest research on human behavior. Plus we always include a brain teaser and a moment of joy. You can sign up at news.hiddenbrain.org that's n-e-w-shiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
社区中展现这种精神的人。我自己也是一名长期的持卡会员。在 discover.com/creditcard 了解更多信息。欲了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请务必查看我们的免费时事通讯。在每一期中，我们都会为你带来关于人类行为的最新研究。此外，我们总是包含一个脑筋急转弯和一个快乐时刻。你可以在 news.hiddenbrain.org 注册，即 n-e-w-s.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。